so und dann heißt es seit dieser woche
endlich ins all
der dreikampf ums kanzleramt letzten
sonntag hat auch die spd ihren
kandidaten offiziell gekürt 96,2 prozent
für olaf scholz die aufholjagd kann
begeben
gut noch hat die spd von der schlimmsten
unions krise seit dem krieg überhaupt
nicht profitiert als einzige partei aber
das kann man ja ändern
die sozen setzen voll auf stolz denn wer
braucht ein team wenn er einen scholz
hat den amtierenden vize-kanzler
die männliche merkel mister 10.000 volt
ja der baumarkt spruch stimmt es gibt
immer was zu tun
das stimmt genau wie spd mach es zu
deinem projekt und wie wo was weiß olaf
tatsächlich könnte man der spd
inzwischen man ein bisschen erholung
oder nach all den nackenschlägen ja mehr
wer soll denn sonst eine vernünftige
opposition abgeben wenn es wirklich zu
schwarz grün kommt im herbst da heißt es
positiv denken mut machen und ja ruhig
auch mal was absurdes erzählen
entscheidend und das wissen wir aber
auch werden die monate august und
september
und wenn die spd eines gezeigt hat dann
war das immer wir können schluss bot
ganz genau
ich meine wer erinnert sich nicht an die
legendären spd schlussspurt 'von
steinmeier steinbrück oder dingsbums der
ist ja am schluss sogar von seinem
eigenen zug überrollt worden
ja das sind voll die schlussspurt
experten dabei könnte jetzt ganz
ernsthaft das zeitalter der
sozialdemokratie anbrechen
denn die soziale frage wird nach coroner
wichtiger denn je wie es aussieht daher
wohl auch das neue lieblingswort von
olaf scholz eine gesellschaft des
respekts kommt nicht von allein
eine politik des respekts an der
gesellschaft des respekt das ist mein
leitbild für deutschland respekt das ist
meine idee für unsere gesellschaft alle
verdienen respekt jede arbeit verdient
respekt sie alle verdienen respekt
respekt
respekt alter 30 mal hat er respekt
gesagt in der rede ich habe mit gezählt
respekt übrigens auch für das tolle neue
zukunftsprogramm der spd
das ist nämlich regelrecht und jetzt
bitte anschnallen links wirklich ein
linkes spd-programm mindestlohn 12 euro
bezahlbares wohnen so eine art mieten
deckel also im grunde all das wovon der
böse koalitionspartner sie die letzten
acht jahre in der regierung böswillig
abgehalten hat die spd quasi ja auf dem
rückweg zur arbeiterpartei
auch wenn das der neue olaf scholz
wahlspot noch nicht so richtig
rüberbringen
er zeigt vor allem wie stinklangweilig
sein alter ist da sitzt also mit seinem
blog wo er alle seine ideen rein
geschrieben hat dann überlegt er wie
bindet man eine krawatte und lässt es
ganz danach lässt er ernsthaft
printzeitung warum weil ihm schlicht
nicht mehr einfällt wie man beim ipad
umblättert kurz trainieren also sehr
kurz dann sieht man wir im willy brandt
haus die putzfrau von der arbeit abhält
arbeiten sie auch hier schließlich fährt
er mit dem fahrstuhl ins büro merkt dann
er hat zu hause seinen ideen block
liegen lassen und fährt direkt wieder
runter sehr rätselhaft
die große frage wie verkörpert man neu
anfangen nach all den regierungsjahren
schwierig wirklich schwierig zumal die
erfolge der groko vom doofen wähler ja
immer angela merkel gutgeschrieben
werden warum auch immer
schreiend ungerecht überlegen sie mal
ihren ehrendoktortitel in harvard hat
sie zum beispiel unter anderem kein
scherz für die einführung der ehe für
alle bekommen
dabei hat die kanzlerin doch vorher
gegen die ehe für alle gestimmt nimmt
den preis aber an gibt es jetzt sogar
als bildband hier die größten spd
erfolge von angela merkel mit super
fotos hier zum beispiel ihre performance
bei der hamburger sturmflut 1962 ohne
sie wäre die stadt abgesoffen oder hier
ihr legendärer kniefall 1970 in warschau
und natürlich ihr größter verdienst die
einführung des mindestlohns hat sie
dafür gekämpft all die jahre hat sie gar
nicht weiß doch keiner so
könnte olaf scholz noch aufhalten auf
seinem weg ins kanzleramt
zum einen natürlich dass er in der spd
ist klar aber vielleicht auch die sache
mit der warburg-bank wir erinnern uns
unter dem ersten bürgermeister olaf
scholz hat die stadt hamburg damals
steuerforderungen in höhe von 47
millionen euro aus kriminellen comex
geschäften gegen die warburg-bank
verjähren lassen
genau dazu hat einen
untersuchungsausschuss in hamburg olaf
scholz gerade noch einmal vorgeladen und
wir schalten live zu unserem reporter
albrecht humboldt vor dem
willy-brandt-haus albrecht kann das dem
scholz noch schaden
falsche frage die richtige frage lautet
ist dieses land schon reif für einen
kanzler mit amnesie oder scholz leidet
unter amnesie ja den spöttischen
unterton können sie sich sparen das ist
eine krankheit
olaf scholz hat sich dreimal mit dem
chef der commerzbank also der rabobank
getroffen während bereits gegen den
ermittelt wurde
aber was er mit dem besprochen hat lenk
absolut nur blanks das wünscht man
keinem
er selbst hat sich da auf
erinnerungslücken berufen wie auch schon
vorher seine verteidigungsstrategie er
kann sich an nichts erinnern
ich finde man kann sich nicht an so
wenig erinnern er könne sich weder an
das treffen selbst noch an den inhalt
der treffen erinnern
er mag sich allerdings nicht mehr daran
erinnern vorüber denn eigentlich
gesprochen worden war er kann sich auch
nicht an die treffen selbst erinnern
diese erinnerungslücken für einen
kanzlerkandidaten sind bemerkenswert
naja also wahlkampf hin oder her aber
eine menschen seine krankheit
vorzuwerfen früh spinne
naja krankheit hat erstmal zwei von den
drei treffen verschwiegen weil er sich
nicht mehr erinnern konnte
zum glück hat der warburg banker
tagebuch geführt
der bank-chef interpretiert scholz
zurückhaltendes verhalten so dass er und
die bank sich keine sorgen zu machen
brauchen im u ausschuss hat scholz
gerade nochmal gesagt zitat die
gespräche liegen viele jahre zurück und
es waren für mich sehr ereignisreiche
jahre
aha wie oft hat denn die stadt hamburg
in seinen regierungsjahren auf 7
und 40 millionen verzichtet ja das weiß
er nicht mehr
ich bin stolz dass wir als gesellschaft
schon so weit sind eine man mit amnesie
das kanzleramt zuzutrauen
das ist gelebte inklusion es gibt sogar
schon einen ersten plakatentwurf olaf
scholz wissen sie vielleicht was ich
letzten sommer getan habe das ist
steuerbetrug eines der großen spd themen
hat norbert walter borjans nicht immer
diese steuersünder cds gekauft ich habe
ihn gefragt er kann sich nicht erinnern
wie jetzt der auch ja man vermutet hier
ist irgendwas in der lüftung vom willy
brandt haus also das ist eine theorie
und ich in der würdigung ich glaube ich
arbeite im willy-brandt-haus wie komme
ich denn da wieder rein
das willy brandt haus das ist ich weiß
es nicht mehr
hallo wo bin ich ist egal albrecht
reimold
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt haye